officers are investigating an
officer-involved shooting in
the area block 1800 block of
Fawn Hedge Avenue. This morning
at just before one thirty,
officers were called to the
area in reference to a domestic
violence situation. During the
incident, a subject was
believed to be armed, fled,
made contact with an officer
during that incident, the
subject was fired upon. He did
sustain a gunshot wound and was
transported to UMC Hospital.
So, as for that, the person is
alive. As for the officer, he
is uninjured. The name of the
officer will come out in 72
hours through press release.
So, as for that, the
surrounding neighborhood is
currently closed off. We do ask
the public that they do avoid
the area for the time being.
Officers will be here for the
next few hours conducting their
investigation as well as
detectives. Though with that,
are there any follow-up
questions? What led the officer
to believe that the suspect was
armed to begin with? This was
due to people calling in and
saying that the subject is
armed. Officer Cuevas, you said
that the the suspect made
contact with the officer. Did
he shoot at him? What what did
you mean by that? So, as for
that, it's still in the
preliminary stages of the
investigation. Detectives are
working out to find details.
More details will come out
later. This domestic violence
call with it something that
happened in the area and then
he left the house or what did
that exactly look like?
Correct. Uh as for that, it
occur inside a residence and
then when the subject fled, he
went to still same similar
area. Um not too far from the
residence and that's where the
OIS did occur. Do we know the
status of the other person
involved in the dispute? As for
the the domestic violence is
the the wife or woman that was
wrong. Uh as for that, it's
it's still preliminary
investigation. So, at this
time, it's believed that it's
only between two subjects. The
suspect a victim Uh the victim
is said to be okay at this
time. Did the victim call the
police? Uh that I don't have
that information. Have you had
any contact with this household
or couple before? A lot of
times domestic violence is
something that occurs over and
over again. Uh as for that, I
don't have the information at
this time but I can definitely
circle back and get to you. Was
there a weapon recovered? Uh I
don't have that information.
Can you clarify the
relationship between the
suspect and the victim? I
cannot at this time. Do they
both live and out to be able
to. Uh that I cannot confirm at
this time.
Anything else you want to add?
No. Thank you. Thank you all so
much. Thank you.